let's come over to purpose now okay
what's the purpose of registration like
could anyone imagine if you are a
government right and people are buying
and selling cars in your country why do
you want them to have their cars
registered yes yeah yeah absolutely
so all these kinds of things that relate
to okay there was a hit-and-run someone
saw the license plate for that car how
are they going to work out who's liable
well it's registered to a name right so
really this is about good record-keeping
that's what you're paying for that
record-keeping real people in the
government have to actually do that so
you we have to pay for their salaries
right that's one thing but also to get a
pink slip right you actually have to or
your dealership before they give you the
car you actually have to get your car
checked to make sure that it's Road
worthy right what kinds of things in a
car might not be Road worthy okay so the
wheels the wheels as you drive and you
go around and you take corners that kind
of fee the tires gradually wear off
right so eventually at some point
someone will look at those wheels as I
hey those are dangerous we can't let you
keep driving me on on those I'm not
going to give you your registration okay
anyone else okay so people might say put
it in a huge engine right or make like
have five exhaust pipes at the end or
something ridiculous like that so
they're not gonna register it if the car
is actually breaking laws okay anyone
else yeah okay so they go to check do
all the indicators work do all the brake
lights brake lights work a little while
ago
don't don't laugh at my actually up
maybe I've got here yeah dude oh no you
can't see the back of the car okay
nevermind so on the back of a car right
so here's here's the back of a car right
and I told you not to laugh right the
brake lights right there the red ones
here and here now by law and I literally
came in like fifteen or twenty years ago
which I know it seems like a long time
for you guys but that's quite recent in
like automotive history there has to be
this third light here right and so in
order for cars to drive on the road they
have to have all three and all three
have to be functioning so at a certain
point in time they
to say and this was generally in
mechanics that have to look at every
aspect of the car go through like a
hundred different points and say okay
this car is weird with you I'll give it
a thumbs up okay so therefore we're talk
about record-keeping just that clerical
stuff but also safety checks right they
cost money and so you have to pay for
that
now because of all of that I'm
registration it generally lasts about a
year registration is transferable okay
so I might buy a comic right brand-new
and I've got 12 months on there and then
the following week you know I see some
hot new thing driving past and I'm like
actually I think I'd like to get that
instead now I can sell my car which will
then have 51 weeks of Reggio left on it
and whoever buys off me maybe one of you
gets those 51 weeks cuz the car's still
roadworthy right it's still been checked
out so this is what we call a
transferable right yeah and if you buy a
second-hand car part of the value of the
car there's small amount but still part
of it is well how much Reggio is still
left on this okay because it's like one
less thing I have to worry about if I'm
buying a second-hand car okay then we
come to stamp duty now stamp duty like I
said it's for actually putting a stamp
on your paperwork it's about this
transferable business here right so a
transfer of ownership happens whenever a
car is purchased right transfer of
ownership this because it's about the
actual transfer you can't transfer it
because every time you buy or sell the
car you have to do this all over again
right so the stamp duty is generally
speaking a percentage I think at that
moment most vehicles will be 3% and um
it depends on a couple of things maybe
you want to UM put some extra space down
the bottom here what does the stamp do
depend on when you have a think about
how much a car is worth you think about
a percentage of that and the more you
sell it for the more stamp duty you're
going to have to pay one of the other
secondary reasons why governments do
this is it stops people constantly
shifting around assets or money in order
to give it to someone who will pay less
tax okay because people try to evade tax
like that because every time you
move the car you have to pay this extra
bit ah one thing I forgot let's come
back to our registration because
registration also the amount that your
power will also change depending on a
few different factors okay so the first
thing is the category of car that it is
a category so for example a motorbike
versus normal force in sedan versus a
ute versus 13c minibus etc all of these
categories of vehicles they attract a
different registration thing and
secondly in terms of registration you
also need to declare what kind of thing
you're going to be using that vehicle
for right is this a business vehicle
like are you actually making money with
this if so your registration will be
more expensive okay right excellent
how are we going so far last one
insurance there are two main kinds of
insurance so I'm gonna talk about does
anyone know what are you them are oh
okay hold on so there's life insurance
that's income insurance there's property
insurance all of those are relevant you
might get interested in them but none of
them have to do with vehicles okay so
let's just think about the cars think
about the cars are Lauren Doris yes what
okay so the first one they talked about
is called it's got a big name compulsory
third-party insurance because of its
name it's often called CTP insurance
just like with registration this also
has a colloquial a don't know what it is
it's called a green slip you've got a
pink slip that's further registration of
the car and then you are a green slip
that's this amount of insurance that you
have to pay you can't drive it's illegal
to drive your car without compulsory
third pay that's why it's called
compulsory now just looking at the name
can anyone guess what it means it's for
other people who are injured or have
been killed during the course of an
actor okay
so what this is is compensation for
injury or death
now importantly it's not injury or death
that you incur it's injury or death that
you cause because you're in an accident
okay so therefore that's why it's called
third parties it's for someone else
right what was there I had told you
there were six things that you'd be
liable to pay the five that we've just
written you need all of those they're
all compulsory but this last one is
optional hooray
so I'm going to put this one as optional
however when I say optional pretty much
everyone buys this so compulsory third
plates very bare-bones you can see it
doesn't cover very much for example if
your car gets totaled or someone else's
car gets total it doesn't cover any of
that cost so you would have to pay that
out of your pocket if an accident like
that happened okay if you want more
cover like something that covers more
different kinds of damage or problems or
accidents that might occur we call this
comprehensive insurance that's exactly
right so comprehensive as it covers more
things now when we have a look at the
different kinds of insurance that are
included and there are lots of different
kinds underneath comprehensive basically
the more you pay on a weekly monthly
basis the more cover that you get okay
so you remember we said compensation for
injury or death of third parties
you can also cover property damage so
for example you accidentally swerve off
the road and you run into someone's
house and you you know you ruin their
front door the front window whatever
okay so that costs a lot of money to
repair in your at fault if you get a
certain amount of copperheads and it
shows it will cover that kind of
property damage it'll also cover theft
sorry that's not a bracket so if your
car gets stolen it'll cover that and it
will also cover your own injury so
remember I said to this one up here this
compulsory third party it's for other
people who get injured right so
comprehensive insurance will cover
injury or death that is for you or
people in your car okay your kind of
life insurance is a little bit different
and it doesn't you don't have to you
could just get injured in an in a
parachuting accident or walking on the
street or whatever has nothing to do
this
surely we'd vehicles okay um okay
now you remember I said to you
registration and stamp duty that kind of
dependent on different things compulsory
third party and comprehensive insurance
they also depend on different things
I'll talk mainly about CTP does anyone
know what kinds of factors will affect
how much you have to pay on compulsory
third party yep very good so things like
say age right things like whether you
are male or female things like the type
of car that you drive because if you're
driving like you know display hot rod
with a really low body you're probably
more likely to get in accidents not less
likely so all these kinds of factors are
involved I'm driving history is also
really important driving history does
anyone know what it's called it has a
special name if you've never had an
accident that you have you know actually
required a power-on insurance for anyone
know what it's called will see your
parents probably have it something
called a boucle bonus don't know if you
ever heard that phrase before if you
have driven well and you've never
actually had to make a claim on
insurance to say hey insurance company I
had an accident can you pay me out for
this you know all my premiums they're
going towards you pay me back for
something if you've never done that
they're like hey you must be a safe
driver so they gave you like this little
incentive to be safe in that way and you
have to pay this alright so there you go
there's an overview lots of little costs
remember I said that asterisk right like
the asterisk is there that's all of this
stuff down here it's all included okay